all right
welcome everybody everyone ready for the
quiz
quiz next week yes i hope you all are
here because
you know that there's a quiz next week
okay so what is this quiz about
it's about what we've talked about so
far in this class of course
what is this class about someone
remember from my first
lecture what is this class about what
are we trying to test you in this class
algorithms great also data structures
right that's what the first part of this
is
but really it's to get you to solve
computational problems that's the first
thing
be able to argue to someone else that
that you actually did solve it
right it's correct right that you chose
something that's better than other
things that it's efficient
right and that you can communicate those
things to other people
right those are my big four that i try
to get you guys to internalize and so
that's what our quizzes
are going to try to evaluate you on okay
and so uh aside from kind of some
mechanic this nitty-gritty kind of stuff
that we do at the beginning of the term
like uh talking about our model of
computation
right our model and like
asymptotics assimtatix is that right
uh recurrences right
aside from these kind of basics we kind
of delve
straight into algorithms right
these are kind of like uh you know
almost definitions we don't rely on
these things very much
i mean we rely on these things all the
time but it's kind of the mathematics
that we use to talk about things right
we
how can we even say how long this stuff
takes unless we can reason
we can abstract a way that this stuff is
not on a real computer
this is kind of in our minds in a
computer and we're reasoning about these
things based on
the number of constant time operations
this magical computer might have
so that you know which is a pretty good
representation of any of the computers
you have
right for certain assumptions right
we're not gonna i mean there's not a lot
of problem set
questions we had you talk about
uh these things like
specifically usually they were part of
some other problem right you
you had to describe the running time of
this thing and you might have had to
solve a recurrence
and you might use master theorem that
kind of thing right or you use
asymptotics all the time
or you need to remember in our model oh
it kind of matters
how big of an integer i can store and do
arithmetic on in constant time
right so for that pset three question
you had at the end
of your the coding question right uh you
you wanted to hash things and you want
you need to argue that those things
fit in a constant number of words so
that
that could be done in constant time a
lot of you guys found
canonicalizations basically mapping to
things that were
exponentially large
so maybe multiplying a product of primes
or something like that
and that would not be a good
representation okay
so the these things come up but they're
not like the main focus of the problems
we solve
what are the main focus of the how do we
solve a computational problem
in this class i kind of gave you two
ways at the beginning of the term do you
guys remember
you can solve how to solve
a computational computational
problem
once the hard way once the easy way
brute force okay so you're describing to
me a technique for making your own
algorithm
right i can just you know
design my new algorithm from scratch one
way i could do that is
brute force it right look at all the
possible outputs and see which one works
right
or i could reduce to something like
divide and conquer or something like
that
that's generally a hard thing to do to
make your own algorithm right
that's why we don't ask you to do it a
lot in this class right it's an 046 kind
of thing right so the first thing you
could do is write
design new
algorithm from scratch
usually it's not from scratch right
usually you're reducing to some kind of
algorithmic design paradigm that you've
maybe heard of
you talk a lot more about it in oh four
six and at the end of this term when we
talk about dynamic programming
but generally that's a hard thing to do
right
you're trying to think of a recursive
algorithm right you're trying to
prove that it's correct to all these
nitty-gritty we we have actually
throughout the class
in lectures have been showing you
the algorithms but we're not really
expecting you to make those algorithms
what are we expecting
you to do most of the time yeah
to reduce it to a problem that we showed
you how to solve right
i'm going to say thing here but really
what i mean is an algorithm that we've
taught you
to be basically here reduced to a known
thing
no to known thing uh
usually that means there's a problem or
an
interface right that that we've given
you
and in general we've shown you multiple
different ways to solve that problem
right or
interface right so we've shown you many
ways
on how to sort things right and we've
shown you many ways on how to implement
sequence and set
interfaces remember and
a lot of times the the types of problems
that we're asking you to do
is to just use as a black box some of
the things that we did
but you need as a programmer as a
computer scientist you need to tell me
when i should use what when right yeah
could you clarify what you mean by uses
uses a black box exactly right um so
this is a phrase that
i use and a lot of people in computer
science use is basically
uh you import a library into your code
right
what do i have i have a kind of an api i
have a way to interact with that code
i don't actually know what's going on
inside of that library
right i'm using it as a black box i it's
opaque to me
i cannot look inside what i mean
actually probably could look inside what
their code is
but i'm not going to the thing that
makes it useful to me
is that it has this useful api that i
trust it to do the things
that you told me that it was going to do
right and so there's kind of
i'm going to jump around a little bit
here actually because
that's a great question uh uh so here
i think of there's kind of three
different types of problems
that we talk about that we give you in
this class you might have seen this on
the problem set
right i i like to categorize them into
kind of three different
categories here one is you kind of have
to understand
the internals of a data structure and
algorithm that we know
right you have to be able to look inside
and i don't know given a node in a
balanced binary search tree an avl tree
right how can i do a rotation
right or how do i do an insert or
uh something about the structure of this
thing
a binary heap right where are the top k
things in a max binary heap which is on
your problem set right
those things require me to very much
not black box these data structures it's
a white box right i need to know what's
inside of that to answer that question
right
i need to know about the internals of
that data structure right
and there are other types of problems
where it's like oh i don't need to know
what the internals of this data
structure is
right i can just operate with knowledge
of the api
right and try to hook it in to the
problem that i need
and that's what i call a reduction type
problem right this is like
how does the core material be presented
to you in lecture work
right this is like how do i apply that
core material
right and harder than both of those
things
right is what i might call a
modification type of pro i mean
these aren't really good names i came up
with these this morning right
but it's trying to get at the the idea
here that
it's possible that you kind of need to
know what the api is and you kind of
need to know what's going on inside
to be able to answer the problem things
like um adapting a divide and conquer
algorithm
right or uh making a instead of using a
dynamic array
that's has extra space on one end maybe
i have to
put extra space in the middle or
something like that right i'm adapting
something
that was from the core material it's
pretty close but i have to modify it in
some way augmentation
right i have to take the vanilla set avl
tree that i might have given you right
and put some other property on the nodes
and you need to tell me how to
maintain that right how can i compute
that subtree property from its children
does that make sense
so kind of this is the harder of the
things
right if you can identify which one of
these
a problem that you look at on an exam
fit under
maybe that can help you kind of
conceptualize what should i use
for a reduction type problem we're going
to talk about this in a section
second but a lot of times it's useful to
reduce it to a problem or an
interface rather than an algorithm
or a data structure what does that mean
does if if i can solve the problem by
saying reducing to sorting
right i can argue to you that that
algorithm is correct i just use sorting
as a black box
no it might not be efficient right my
choice of sorting algorithm that i chose
matters right for efficiency but for
correctness it doesn't matter
right for a data structures problem i
might reduce to using
two set data structures and a sequence
data structure or something like that
right but uh
it will be correct if i reduce it to
those things right
i can define the operations in terms of
those
those interfaces i don't have to make
that choice until i talk about running
time
right until i talk about efficiency and
the name of the game on the quiz to get
points we can't give you points for an
incorrect algorithm
right or something that's pretty close
to correct right
uh and we can't give you full points
unless the correct algorithm you give us
is efficient
right and that you've argued things like
correctness and
running time and things like that right
like your algorithm could be
correct uh and efficient but you analyze
the running time
incorrectly so we mark your points off
for there or you
you most of the time what you do is you
present us with an inefficient algorithm
and then you analyze the running time as
if it's the target running time that we
gave you
right that's bad on two fronts right
okay so try not to fall into these traps
okay so some
general test taking strategies when
you're looking at your quiz
i really strongly urge you to read
through the entire exam before you start
right because some of the problems will
be easier for you than others
if you're trying to maximize points on
here
right as all of you i'm sure are trying
to do uh
it's use useful to make that initial
pass through the problems
to see which ones are easiest for you
right and then you can tackle them
in the the order in which you have
confidence
now in actuality the average on
say quiz 1 of this class tends to be
around
i don't know between a 60 and an 80. i
don't think it's ever been 80 but
right uh but you know it's it's not a
100
right so doing 50
of the problems well right
is probably gonna be better for you in
terms of time management
and you know those kinds of things then
doing all of the
like attempting all of the problems and
not doing great on any of them right
in terms of appointment right you have
to in computer science you have to be
pretty close to a correct answer to get
points
right it basically needs to be almost
correct or
you don't get if if you've seen how your
problem sets are being graded sometimes
our problem
set graders make mistakes sometimes they
accept give you points for for uh
an incorrect solution right it's really
on you to take a look at your
problem sets that you gave us and our
solutions that we gave you we spent a
lot of time
writing good solutions for you guys you
need to make sure that you know the
material
don't come up to us at the end of an
exam and say
oh i said the same thing on my problem
set it was marked correct
and you guys marked it wrong well yeah
the staff knows a little bit more about
algorithms than
your graders on your problem sets and we
grade your exams
so unfortunately that's not an excuse
right it's on you to know the material
yep so are most of the problems on the
exams are like
multiple part things where we need to
like have a good understanding and
do like the first few parts right in
order to get even partial pressure on
the other parts or is it like
we yeah so the question is uh is it
kind of our questions built
on top of each other right so that
you're kind of at a wall if you miss the
first part
right we try not to design exams that
way okay you can actually take a look at
the practice exam that's already been
posted right they te
our problems tend to be self-contained
and if they are multiple parts
the parts are usually independent right
usually you don't need to have done a
correctly in order to do b
correctly right and that's how our
problem sets try to be written as well
right
for your last the coding question on
psat4
right you had this problem where you had
to design this data structure
right but c said use that as a black box
essentially
and solve the problem right so you
actually don't need to show
we've given you this interface right you
can just use that interface to be able
to answer
c the algorithms question without even
solving the data
structures question correctly does that
make sense and actually that was
the algorithm's question was the easier
one there i think from what i remember
yeah do we have to write code on the
exam do you have to write
code on the exam uh
i've never given an exam where you've
had to
write code i have written exams where
you have to read code
okay so pseudocode or python right
but since python's a prerequisite for
this class it's completely fair game
that we give you
small snippets of python code and you
have to to be able to understand what's
going on
yup um you listed amortization
what i mean here right amortization
certainly appears in
here or here right these kinds of things
right oftentimes like
if i'm using a dynamic ray if i'm using
a binary heap if i'm using a hash table
right amortization will appear here in
our running times right
for those dynamic operations what i mean
here in amortization i mean like
if i'm asking you to generalize
something that we've done like with
dynamic arrays
where instead of adding additional space
at the end
i'm putting additional space in the
middle or at the beginning
or something like that and you're having
to do some kind of
amortized analysis now often it's
unnecessary to do this right in in uh
when we talked about a problem where we
did
do our own amortized analysis of making
a double-ended
deck right i mean a double-ended queue
you could actually solve it by reducing
to using two
uh dynamic arrays right so
there there's uh there's a lot of ways
in which
you could reduce to using things but you
might have to do some additional
bookkeeping at the end right
but what this is saying is that these
are more
you're not using things as a black box
you're changing something about the
boxes that we gave you right does that
make sense
yeah if you tell us to write an
algorithm that does something in like
o log n time and we can think only of an
algorithm that does something
inefficiently like o oh event time okay
then is that any point rising sure so
let's actually
move uh on for a second
i actually there's
i'm going to answer your question very
soon okay
uh but i'm gonna get to it in a second
okay
if i don't rhyme if i don't answer that
question in five minutes
please let me know okay so so the first
thing what i'm
approaching a problem on on the exam i
might try to
ask some questions about the problem
okay it's going to help me decide what
to use
right different than your problem sets
right
your problem sets basically what do you
use is
what did we talk about in lecture that
week right on a quiz
you have eight lectures that you've
talked about and so this is going to be
a harder thing for you to do
right because you don't know which of
the eight lecture material
is going to apply to this problem and it
could be a combination of them actually
right and so
i'm trying to give you ways of answering
that question faster okay
so uh is this a mechanical reduction or
a modification type problem that's just
going to help me
determine kind of the difficulty level
of what this is you might not be able to
answer it
right but it can give you a sense for
what kind of problem it is
is this a problem about data structures
sorting both
right uh if it's about data structures
do i need to support sequence type
operation so i need to store
an extrinsic order on something or is it
a
thing where i i care about what the
objects are i'm trying to look things up
by what they are
right or maybe both or maybe some
combination right if i've
a bunch of different types of keys that
i might want to query on
right i might have to use at least two
set type of data structures right yeah
you could get very complicated with
these things but putting it in terms of
well i'm going to need to do this kind
of operation on
this these names right
then i can think oh i need a set data
structure there i'll think about how to
implement that
later should i use a hash table should i
use a sorted array should i use a avl
tree right
but you know thinking about it first at
the abstract level of
i need to set data structure here right
can help you compartmentalize
correctness
versus efficiency does that make sense
okay uh
if if you're stuck this is your question
if you're stuck right write down a
correct algorithm that's inefficient
right we can give you points for a
correct algorithm that's inefficient at
least it's a correct algorithm
right that's better than other things
right now if it's really if
it's exponential time you might be
limited to like
10 or 20 of the points right but if it's
you know a log factor
worse or a linear factor worse
maybe that's okay right on a data
structures problem if any operation
takes
order n time that's probably not going
to give you a lot of points because the
whole point of the data structure is to
make those operations fast
right but you know if it if it solves
the problem you'll get some
some points you won't get zero points
yeah
will we get any questions how fast can
you make this make this as fast as
possible yeah so a lot of times we'll
say
give us an efficient algorithm okay it's
like
well i don't know if it's efficient or
not well that just means that faster
running times are going to give you more
points okay so
in in questions like that it's mostly
uh trying to play this game of
usually we'll put an efficient one in
not in terms of a data structure
because usually a data structure problem
it's important
in your implementation that these data
structure operations be fast
and we want to tell you that what how
fast is right
so dynam data structures uh questions in
general
uh there's usually a trade-off between
the
the running times of these different
operations and it's really important
how they relate to each other and so for
data structures problem it's kind of
about
getting those running times okay with an
algorithms problem
right where we ask you to do one thing
right and we try to do as fast as
possible
you know try to get linear time right
most of the time you can't
get better than linear time if you have
to read
the entire input at some point right
like if i want to find the things in my
data right
and if you can't think of a linear time
algorithm you know
think of an n squared thing or think of
an n log n thing right
maybe that's a little hard for you guys
to think of
right now right but that's why i'm
saying
start with any correct algorithm and
then maybe you can optimize maybe you
can use a better data structure to make
it more efficient does that make sense
any other questions okay
moving right along okay here's
some downsides right okay
if you find yourself doing one of these
three things
take a step back you're probably doing
something wrong okay
so question yourself if you're trying to
compute decimals
rationals or real numbers i can't store
those things on a
i mean i can store decimals to finite
precision right but if you're doing
finite precision you might as well round
like multiply your numbers by that fixed
precision and deal with integers
right we only have taught you how to
deal with integers in this class right
we haven't even shown you how to
efficiently
compute on rationals and real numbers we
have
told you if you have a denominator in
the numerator of a fraction
i can take two fractions and compare
them
right in constant time by doing cross
multiplication but
if i'm trying to actually do this
division
right to arbitrary precision that's not
that's not happy right because i can't
even represent that on my computer
infinite number of
decimal points for some of these things
right
uh if you're trying to use radix work
for every answer
it's probably wrong right one of the
things that we try to do
on our quizzes right we're not just
giving you a bunch of problems
randomly right we probably are making
problems that
cover the material in some way right we
do want to test you on all of the things
right
and so if uh if you find that you're
using the same thing
four or five times on the exam that
might be a sign that
you're using it too many times it's not
always the case right sometimes hashing
is super useful
right so you want to use it all the time
but in particular
right everyone tries to use radix sort
when it's inappropriate
right and they love right because it
gets linear time
right but if you
if you write merge sort for something
where radix sort will apply you'll get
some points because it's correct but not
efficient
right if you're and it's inefficient by
a log factor
right if you're trying to use radix sort
in a
situation where comparisons are the
answer and you don't have a bound on the
integers
if i don't have a bound on the size of
the integers then this may be taking
a huge amount of time right so i'm gonna
i
might not even think of that as being
correct because you know it could be
exponential time
right or it could i mean i don't know i
don't know how big my word size is it
could be real
arbitrarily bad okay uh
and then if you're trying to augment a
binary tree with something that's not a
subtree property
right something that can't be computed
from the augmentations of its two
children
you're doing something bad i every exam
we
have 30 of students
say augment by my index
in the entire tree right
or augment by here's one that's fun uh
augment by the things
the size of my left subtree
okay how like the number of nodes in my
left subtree
how can i like
how i'm not sure how i can maintain that
with rotations and things like that
uh let's see to in order for me to
keep track of the augmentation of my
left tree
from the augmentation of my left tree
right i kind of have to do a logarithmic
walk all the way down the thing to
figure out how many things were there
right
so that's not a maintainable thing in
constant time if i want to augment
something of my left subtree
just augment the thing itself and just
look at your left subtree and look at
its augmentation does that make sense
yeah if you had to say i've mentioned it
with the subtree and then augmented
again with left subtree and then you
you could do that you could do that yeah
so you could do that in constant time by
augmenting by
subtree size right yeah then have
another augmentation
you could have another augmentation
because then you could just look at but
then just look
look at your subtree please yeah no no
reason to store it again right you just
do one constant time
look to your left right okay don't do
that
okay so that is
cool i'm not that far behind those are
my tips on
solving questions oh there's one more
page yeah so like when defining an
augmentation
exactly right so the the idea is
if you give an augmentation that's not
uh
stand like we're going to talk about our
standard things you can reduce to in a
second
right if i if you're saying i'm going to
take a set avl tree
right or a sequence avl tree
and like for example at the end of
lecture we were talking about how
a sequence avl tree could
be modified to support priority queue
operations
in the same running times as binary
heaps right
and that was saying we store our subtree
maxes
right the max thing in my subtree right
and so that's a different augmentation
than what's already augmented on the
sequence avl what's uh what what are the
augmentations on a sequence avl tree
size uh so count is the same thing as
how many nodes are in my subtree and
height right because it's an avl tree
right so if i'm augmenting by max
in my subtree that's not part of my
standard interface
so you need to tell me that right even
though we've done it before it should be
very easy for you
right just say i'm augmenting by my max
max can
be computed as the max between me and my
left and right subtree if they exist
done right but just do that right you
have to tell me
and and it takes constant time so it can
be maintained in constant time
when i'm doing my stuff does that make
sense
okay so uh the last thing i guess
especially
on the data structures problems i would
suggest
that you approach these things by by
solving these problems just in terms of
the interfaces
first right because then at least you
get something that's correct
right and then choose the algorithms or
data structures that you use
to implement those interfaces afterwards
right
one gets you to a correct algorithm the
other is for efficiency
right decoupling these might help you in
solving the problem
if if it doesn't help you don't right
right if you're like
whenever i see a set data structure i'm
gonna probably use a hash table
that's probably fine right but if we're
looking for worst case time bounds
that's probably not fine right so you
just
you i i'm asking i'm suggesting that you
separate these things
uh so that you concentrate on solving
the problem first
and then optimize it later yeah
it doesn't imply that it is that right
so
i mean you could have a data structure
whose expected time bound is constant
but it's worst case bound is n log n
right it just happens to be the
fact that for a hash table those worst
case operations are
linear right so but if i had we had a
question
up here beforehand right if i had a a
running time bound that
i did something to a hash table right in
constant expected time
right i did a look up and then i
i queried an avl tree for the
predecessor of a node or something like
that
and i did that in o of log
and time what's the worst case running
time of that
o of n right what's the expected running
time of this thing
login expected login right because it's
possible that in the worst case it could
be higher
that make sense okay
uh uh
so okay the second bullet is
just setting up a data structures
problem right there's a lot of moving
parts
we're gonna do two data structures
problem at the end of this session
right describe all of the
data structures you're using right
including what they store right if
you're storing a set data structure
you better tell me what the things
you're stored are keyed on
right usually the things that we're
storing contain a bunch of information
and if you just say i'm storing all of
the toppings
of my pizza right in a set data
structure
and that's all you tell me i have no
idea what you're talking about because i
don't know what the semantics of your
set data structure are what is it keyed
on
right i have to say oh it's keyed on i
don't know
the y's or something like that right
okay and they're in variance right what
how we're setting up these data
structures problem
usually how i solve these when i'm
writing the solutions
i set you up a state right
of what this data structure could be at
some instance right
i'm going to say this data structure
stores all of the things less than k
with with key less than k blah blah blah
right and this one stores the
uh the extrinsic order of
the items based on blah blah blah right
okay
so actually me stating what they store
in that way
right is actually imposing some kind of
invariant
on these data structures that i'm
wanting to maintain right
but what i need to do to prove that this
thing is correct is that
based on the assumption that those
invariants
held before my operation right
then i can prove that an operation is
correct if all of those main
those those invariants are maintained at
before then after the operation right
that's kind of how i'm
proving that this thing is correct and
then when i'm querying i'm doing some
kind of lookup on this data structure
i can rely on those invariants i know
that those things are good
right those things have been maintained
and so i can rely on those to look up
uh what's the largest k of this thing
does that kind of make sense
this is very abstract we're going to get
a little bit more
concrete in just a second and then uh
implement
every operation i you have no idea how
many solutions we
read on the quizzes right which we give
you
three operations to implement and you
don't even mention one
and it's usually the easiest one it's
like insert it into your data structure
it's like come on just say that right we
can't give you points unless you
mention that operation does that make
sense
uh and then it's going to help us re
happy graders give you more points not
not really right like but if your
solution
is well organized and well labeled and
things like that
then we're going to be able to
comprehend your solution better
and we'll be able to give you more
points remember part of this class is
about communication if your thing is
correct
but we can't tell what you're saying
then it's not correct
right right okay
all right so uh now we get to any
questions on that
what are the data yeah that we've
discussed in the past are you still
interested
variants are like those that adl right
so
if it's the standard things we're going
to talk about what the standard things
are
now uh then you don't need to re-argue
or restate all i mean you can you can
basically say like
uh because the set and sequence
interfaces
are defined that way these things are
correct like almost
like obvious you can you can basically
we you're trying to convince us that you
know why it's correct
right if you guy if you're correctly
using a set or a sequence data structure
in these
data structures type problems then
unless you're using it in a way that is
unusual
right uh usually you can just rely on
the properties of the set and sequence
data structures that we gave you
i do want you to mention that you
thought about correctness right
right like this um
this data structure is correct because
right
just write a sentence saying that right
and arguing
that you're you're basically maintaining
the invariance of your data structure
kind of at the upper level right what
kinds of things are is this data
structure storing
what what main things about the
global data structure are we relying on
to make query operations as long as you
are are convincing that after a dynamic
operation where i'm
modifying the data structure that those
invariants stay the same
that are are still satisfied
then then that's really all you need to
say right you
these these invariants are are satisfied
because
of the definitions of the set and
sequence data structure right like
a lot of times it doesn't require a lot
of thought for the
we're not asking the the reason why we
do reduction problems
right is so that you don't have to do a
lot of work to prove to us that it's
correct right
we have these really nice black boxes
they are correct we proved them
to you that they're correct and so you
don't have to redo that work
okay so now we're going to go through
uh kind of the core material i like to
think about in this class
this class the first part of this class
aside from these
you know mathematical
tools that we develop at the beginning
of the course it's mostly about solving
problems involving
data structures and we motivated this
problem of sorting
by saying that a sorted array is a data
structure that's actually pretty useful
right but how do we sort those things uh
well we
showed you a bunch of ways to do that
right
and this is that nice table lots of
stuff right why do we show you so many
sorting algorithms why don't we just
give you one algorithm
yeah different runtimes
better for different scenarios
yeah you'll notice in this table
right there's not blue all the way
across for any of these things
right so some of them are better for
different scenarios and actually these
comments kind of
list some special cases where these
things might be better
right in in actuality this ultra blue
thing
is saying like this could be linear time
that's better right
but in some cases this is worse than all
the other things
right so be a little wary of this blue
color here
okay generally we're trying to get you
down
further down in this chart if you can
right
and in general uh
like for example merge sort avl sort
these are really the same in terms of
asymptotic complexity and
kind of the way in which you interact
with these sorting algorithms
um but there are special cases where you
might
use insertion sort or selection sort
actually i'm not sure about
insertion sort i i there you had a
in your recitation two days ago
uh i think you guys showed how to do
uh if you had a k proximate array where
things are not
more than k away from each other
insertion sort actually runs in n times
k and so if k is small then that's
really good that's
kind of like linear but you can actually
do even better
with a binary heap which you saw in
recitation hopefully
where you can get that down to n log k
by
keeping maintaining a heap as you go
across and finding the max that way
okay uh so insertion sort maybe is
not so great but uh selection sort right
the
the name of the game there is that uh
if my reads
are cheap but my rights are expensive
right
uh selection sword actually does pretty
well because i only have to do
sorry my reads are cheap and my rights
are yeah expensive right
selection sword only does a linear
number of swaps right it's looking down
finding the max swapping it in and keep
going right
and so in such cases that's actually
better than
any of these other algorithms that we've
got yeah
um worst case er expected this is worst
case
okay so it's a little hard to put there
was a lot of moving parts to get to this
bound
uh in on in tuesday's lecture right uh
basically what we did we showed you how
to think of an array as a heap
as a binary tree right complete binary
tree
it's not an avl i mean it is an avl tree
but
like avl trees are weaker than a
complete
tree right height balance is a weaker
property than a complete
right the the reason why we use complete
is because
it's unique for a number of nodes right
that way i when i give you one array
with a fixed length
i know exactly what tree you're talking
about because there's a one-to-one
mapping there right if i i can't if
i there was it some ambiguous ambiguity
on
what tree i was talking about i wouldn't
heaps just wouldn't work
right so what what heapsort does is
it has this correspondence between
arrays and binary trees
and then what it does is uh provides
these operations that kind of
only do operations at the end right and
then the
in-place optimization is that well
instead of actually popping it or
pushing it onto the back of an array
i'm just going to think of a subset of
my array as
a heap and then always
kind of pooping the max out to the end
right just leaving it behind and
thinking of my heap as a smaller
subset right and that's how we got
it it didn't actually use any
amortization
uh for the time bound
time bound you could actually do this
with the amortized basically dynamic
array
version of this the time bound doesn't
rely on that the in place
relies on you know key staying all
within one array does that make sense
that you're doing a bunch of amortized
operations so that this actually does
achieve worst case and login yeah
it seems that like the things you're
learning
not like they tend to be better so
assume that most algorithms you wanted
them to be you know
faster it seems like we will not use as
often especially in the exam as well
insertion and selection
right yeah so there are these special
cases where they're good right
but i mean uh you know generally
these are better general data structures
for most situations that you come across
i mean there are cases where those other
things are good so you don't want to
completely ignore them
right but generally uh yeah
you're trying to be lower down in this
chart what i mean is that if i don't
have an exam like i'm using them all
except for like
selection servers so there's too many
things on here for us to test all of
them on an
exam okay so don't be afraid if not
everything is covered
worry when things are covered 18 times
on the exam that's not good right
okay so for radix sort there are
situations where
right you get linear time right it's
when you're polynomially bounded
is there are there times when i want to
use radix sort when i'm not polynomially
bounded in my
integers
well if you're not polynomially bounded
then that could take a really long time
sure yeah but like where's the
uh this will be worse than n log n when
right it's definitely better than n log
n when u
is polynomially bounded right because
it's linear
n to the n okay so if i put
n to the n in here right i get an n
factor that comes out here that gives me
a quadratic running time
which is not great okay but when will
this be
better than n log n
yeah uh into the c mu
so that'll definitely give us linear
time right that's what this is saying
but we can actually do better than n log
n
if this u is n to the
c times log n right for some c
right if it's if it's asymptote like if
it's n to the c
log log n right that's smaller than log
n right so that's a better
algorithm right that's a faster album do
you guys
see why we wrote these things this way
is so that we give you a more precise
about it's
it's this is more important for you
understand what you means here
then that this thing sometimes runs in
linear time right
we want to know you when it runs in
linear time
right does that make sense or when it
runs faster than merge sort
does that make sense okay
so that's sorting
we have sequence type data structures
right we have linked lists we have
dynamic arrays we have sequence abl's
sequence avails are great i don't know
why no one teaches it
they're great they don't teach it
probably because they're
actually not that useful right they
you don't actually use the insert in the
middle
a lot right in coding right so it's it
you can usually get around with like
shifting something to the end and doing
dynamic operations there right
and that's a lot of the games that you
try to play so you don't have to make
your own data structures
and you can just use the python list
that's in your
in like native to your thing right but
here it has a theoretical interest
because it gets these kind of bounce
bounds
if you need to insert in the middle of
this sequence right
uh now some of you look at me and
had a question before right that was
like
but jason how does
linked list operations on the end
of a linked list why does that take
linear time
it's because in lecture we presented you
with what
a singly linked list right it just had
pointers
to the next thing right and if i only
have pointers to the next thing and a
pointer to the head
for me to find the end right
i need to walk all the way down the list
right
now let's say i keep my pointer to the
tail
then finding that end one is fine but
removing it
still takes linear time because i don't
know what came before me
right and so that's why in pset whatever
one two i don't remember you stored a
pointer back to your previous one that
gave you doubly linked lists
yay right so actually expanding this
table out
you can reference a doubly linked list
here and get this one as constant
time does that make sense and
uh this one still linear time right
okay uh but this one's still linear time
uh we all actually also showed you how
to do this in constant amortize
do you guys remember that that was in
problem session
two or one i don't remember remember it
was whatever we were talking about
uh amortized stuff right we got we got
actually both of these to
one amortized using the concepts of the
dynamic array right
and then we actually did it one more
time where we got a good doubly ended
thing
what was that does anyone remember
we went to problem session three yeah
so qdq those are talking about
double-ended things
those are implemented in a certain way
right which is actually one of these
things
it's actually i think this one in python
uh but uh there's a we used a different
data structure
to get something that had really good at
right
it had really good pop and append
and first and last dynamic operations do
you guys rem
anyone remember problem session three
that's that's what this was right
okay we got one that had expected bounce
does that help
i heard someone say it hash table
yeah so what basically you did you
instead of
you this is a sequence thing these
things don't have keys
right but i could identify with each
item as i stick it in a key representing
its index right
and i could use a hash table that way
now there was some difficulty
right if i removed the first thing
right or right because
actually how how those all of my indices
have now changed right
but if i just store what the smallest
index in my thing is
then then i'm golden because i can
compute what that
index should be right as i as i change
things at the front
okay so there's actually three different
ways we showed you of getting constant
time at the front and the back of this
thing
so actually you can think of that as
standard material that you can reduce
too
okay that's the like one exception of
the things that i'm not showing on this
chart
but is a bonus if you're watching this
problem session yeah
so isn't it a set data structure though
it is
right but it's we used it to implement a
sequence data structure
so i will refer you to that problem
session if you want to learn more about
it
okay so any questions on sequence data
structures yeah
uh yeah uh should we be or
yeah should we be able to like prove the
tables that were given
so uh i would hope
i hope that if i gave you a blank table
that you would be able to fill it out
right that's how well i want you to know
how these things are implemented
i'm we're not going to have that on the
exam right that's a boring kind of
question
but it is important to know yeah i i
would um
you know it's good for you to think like
oh if i'm going to use an avl tree
right operations are generally going to
be login right that's a really useful
thing
or if i'm going to use a hash table
right dictionary type operations you
know finding inserting and deleting
those are fast doing order type
operations on hash
hash tables is bad that's hard to do
because i have to basically look through
all my things
right knowing that dynamic operations on
the sorted array is bad
right or knowing that you know
you have to think about here what we
mean when we say linked list in dynamic
array on this table
right because you've yeah exactly we are
implying singly linked here because
that's what we
presented to you in lecture and so those
are the standard things that we want you
to reduce so the three modified standard
things are the double needless the
double-ended brand
yeah basically you can assume that you
have a doubly
it's this one that you probably want to
use right because you get
constant indexing right and then pretty
good
on both ends right but you know
if you need a double ended queue you can
also reduce it to having two
dynamic arrays back to back one going
this way when going this way
and so there's lots of way we're not
going to give that to you as a standard
method because there's literally like
four methods we showed you how to do
right so you choose one okay yeah
[Music]
like if we want to say like we do this
thing with the sequence available
and it takes long end time like do we
have to like say the sentence like
because it's a sequence
it takes longer time because this or can
we just like say like her at the table
yeah no if you just if you told me that
you're storing things in a sequence avl
right and you just say you basically say
what you do to it
and you say which takes blah blah blah
time you don't need to say because it's
a
sequence avl right because you already
told us it's a sequence of well
i believe that you probably wrote the
chart on your cheat sheet and you looked
it up
okay all right uh any other questions on
this
no yeah just to make sure the
links list will make the insert line set
in the results
the old one so yes
double a-link list gives this guy
constant time
and actually there are two operations
here uh insert delete and
i guess there's a find here as well
right
if i just store the tail pointer that
gets defined to constant time
right but it doesn't get the dynamic
ones to constant time
right i need to store the previous
pointers as well at each node does that
make sense
okay uh lastly
or i guess second to lastly set data
structures
there are a little bit more of these not
so many more
but uh but yeah
uh we had a sorted array gets good find
but is not dynamic
right
we have set avl tree which does pretty
good find
and is dynamic again you get this
uh log n log n overhead to build because
essentially what you're doing with both
of those data structures is to sort
right
but if i'm looking on a theory question
right like i'm not asking you something
specifically about a sorted array
right if you have a choice between this
data structure and this data structure
which one
do you choose
well i don't quite know because it's
almost like this one's better at
everything except for this one right
but can anyone tell me how to make this
one constant time as well
augmentation right i could just store in
my sub trees the max or min
right and i can make this one strictly
better than this one
right so in a theory problem you
probably just want to use this one
right uh here hash tables direct access
arrays
even better for these operations that's
great
but they suck at these that's right so
if you need these
don't use these right and in actual
coding right especially if you're
coding in a language that's not python
something that doesn't automatically
give you a hash table right if you're in
c
in a microcontroller lab in in at mit
here
you're taking 6 1 15 or whatever right
like and you're doing assembly
right usually what you're doing is a
direct access stuff
right because that's giving you the
jumps that you need in machine language
to actually go
and access this constant time that's
generally if you have control over the
keys that you're putting
that you're putting in your data
structure you don't want this
overhead of com running your keys
through a hash function to look these
things up
you just store the things in array right
you use the hash table when you don't
have control over the keys
or your keys are like strings or
something right
so that's when you use the hash table
now for our purposes usually
you know a hash table is just as good
unless we're asking you for worst case
bounds
right and if we we're going to do this
when we talk about the data structures
problem
if we give you a situation where we
don't
care if you achieve worst case or
expected or amortized or any of these
things we'll just say
make sure you state which one you
achieve
right and as long as you analyzed it
correctly with respect to your data
structures then
you're fine right but if we say you
better do worst case here
i'm going to slap you around right then
please get those bounds right don't
don't use a hash table in that case
that make sense okay uh
lastly we've got priority queues which
we talked about
i'm not going to go through this one
very much it's basically just adding
this to the thing
but in actuality you can get all of
these bounds with a
set avl i mean a sequence avl tree with
max or main augmentation which isn't on
this list because we didn't really talk
about it but
hopefully you can if you need these
bounds
without the amortization then then you
could achieve them
okay all right so those are that's
basically
everything that we've talked about in
the class okay we're going to spend the
rest of the time working a couple data
structures problem
i'm not there's there's a number of
different types of questions you'll
actually
um see on uh
on the quiz the practice quiz that we
gave you from last term
there's some what i call mechanical type
questions up
at the front right then usually some
reduction
type problems where you're reducing to
using some sorting algorithms or some
data structures
and then usually the latter ones are
ones where you have to do some kind of
something additional like some
augmentation or some you know divide and
conquer or something like that
right okay uh so
we're going to go ahead and spend the
rest of the time working a couple of
these problems
these were from spring of 2019 on the
exam
uh and actually one of the tas
who's ta in for us now was also taking
for us
spring 19 was grading problem number two
here the rainy research problem
and just hated me because no one did it
right so
all right so
let's try to solve these problems so
problem one this is about
restaurant store
yes okay all right uh so basically
what's happening
uh popular restaurant criminal seafood
what's the reference legal seafood yes
opposite
does not take reservations but maintains
a wait list where customers
who have been on the waitlist longer are
seated earlier uh sometimes customers
decide to eat somewhere else so the
restaurant must remove them from the
waitlist okay
uh assume that a customer has a
different name
no two customers are added to the wait
list at the exact same time
right so there's an kind of an ordering
at which people are being added to this
waitlist right does that make sense
design a database to help criminal
seafood maintain its wait lists
supporting the following operations each
in constant time okay so here we're
we've refactored the running time up to
the top
uh and it's oh sorry i added the build
here
i guess that's still constant that's
fine okay yeah
state whether each running time
operation is uh
worst case amortized expenses so when
you see that statement
you're saying okay i'm allowed to use a
hash table if i want to
right i just have to make sure if i use
one
i label my operations expected and
amortized
when they occur right which which
operations are expected basically all of
them
which operations are amortized the ones
that changed
what's in the data structure right
insert delete
okay so we've got some operations
building an empty thing
adding a name so this name is x to the
back of the waitlist
what do i know about x what do i know
about the names per
our assumptions in this class they're
all unique
they're unique so they can be a key and
they fit in a constant number of words
by our assumption right so i can compare
two of them in constant or i can hash
one in constant time
right that's kind of the assumption we
make on these inputs they're strings
and i didn't assign you a bound on their
length so
you it's probably not something you need
to worry about right
okay remove a name right
so already i'm feeling like i need to be
able to find things by their name
right okay uh and then
see it's the next person in line does
that make sense
so what kinds of things do i need to
maintain here i i've
i have people right they have names and
they have kind of places
right the time that they came in right
but am i given the times
no i'm not given times anywhere right
it's not on the inputs to my operations
right so it's not like i'm going to be
able to key on times
does that make sense what's the
important part about the times
the order right yeah basically
whenever i'm basically trying to
maintain a sequence on these guys right
there's a front one and a back one and
people in the middle
right and i want to make sure that order
stays the same or else people are
getting angry at me
right because ah they came here after me
and ready to go to city
yeah right you've been in that situation
okay so uh we're trying to maintain some
kind of sequence
an extrinsic order on these things right
but we're also needing to be able to
look up people by their name
because i want to be able to change this
thing right does this maybe sound
familiar to some other
problem we had on this pro this terms
problem sets
yeah i think there was a problem where
uh
the chat right right you had to store a
sequence right
but you also had this dictionary that
you had to look things up right
now the nice thing about that um
situation
right is that the things that you needed
to look up on
was static right and so what could i use
for my dictionary my
my sets data structure for that
anyone remember you could just use a
sorted array right because it's static
these things aren't updating all the
time right and so it was fine for me to
just use a static array
right here uh
and and we gave you lookup times that
were worst case logarithmic right
here i'm asking for constant time right
sort a sorted array is not going to cut
it set avail is not going to cut it so
what i'm going to use
a dynamic array or a hash table right
now dynamic array might not be great
because i don't actually have a numeric
bound on how big these
keys are i just know that they fit in
words right
so i can't actually make a direct access
array because
those words while they fit in a constant
number of words i don't know if the
integer representation of those are
polynomially bounded
does that make sense right so i do want
to use hashing in this
in this case right and so what do i want
to maintain i want to maintain a
sequence data structure
uh on
customers
customers is there you in there
somewhere no this is right right
okay and a set uh
mapping so you this is usually how i do
it like i want to say a set
keyed on something if it's just a set
then i just have it key right i can look
up whether that thing is there or not
but when it's i'm i'm actually having it
mapped to something else i'll say
you know mapping a key space to
something else usually the item that i'm
storing
or maybe some property of the items that
i've stored right does that make sense
okay so mapping what do i map here
names right
to oh to what do i want a map
the time the time that they entered do i
want to do that
we can't exactly do it with the time
that they enter but the secrets of the
customers will show what's next and what
yeah kind of i want to i want to store
it to where it is in this sequence right
so i'll just store the index where it is
in the sequence and i can just look it
up right that sounds
yeah indices change every time i add or
remove things right
ah yeah store a pointer right
pointer
to place in
sequence now uh that's a little weird to
say
because i haven't told you how i
represented this sequence
right but you know conceptually
i can say i'm storing a pointer to some
place in this that represents where it
is i'll deal with
the details of that later okay right
but generally i call this a linked data
structure right because i'm linking
between two data structures right
so that i can do a query in one say and
find out where it is in the other
right or do a query in the other right
that kind of thing okay so everyone kind
of understand
why i chose these things right how i
approach this problem yeah
i'm not sure how a pointer fixes the
problem
of just storing an index you know
like the the place that the person is at
and the sequence is going to change over
time
assuming that the pointer updates with
that change so
okay so let's say uh if
if every time so let's say i'm storing
let's say i'm storing this sequence in a
linked list
let's just say because i know that i'm
going to have to be inserting deleting
things from the middle of this thing
does that make sense right so i'm going
to go ahead and
say that this is going to be a linked
list okay and now i have this
linked list
okay so if i said
all right this set data structure my set
stores point to or stores where it is in
the linked list right
say it's stored at at
uh k right cool
now if i seat this guy
right i stick him at his table
right every index has changed right
so for me to update the indexes stored
in this set data structure
i have to change every single one of
them yeah does that make sense
yeah no this makes any more sense yeah
so really what i want
not to store a number here but an actual
pointer to the node that's containing
this thing
right because the node isn't changing
unless that thing
left my data structure right the node
the address of the this thing
in memory the the the node is just a
little container that contains an item
and the next pointer and actually we're
going to need a previous pointer here
right we're going to need a double
a-link list right
because what we're going to do when we
remove something we need to stitch it
back together
in constant time which means we need to
know what's the one in front of us and
the one behind us
right yeah okay all right so
link list here we already said maybe
using a hash table here
right and so okay great
this is basically enough for me to say
this is my data structure these are the
invariants what are the invariants
it's storing all the customers right
that's an inver
i mean it's not a very strong invariant
but it's i mean
i i should say that right i'm storing
all the customers because i'm
i'm gonna have to make sure that i'm
maintaining that when i do a query
right and then here set mapping names to
pointers right the place in this thing
right and as i remove things i need to
make sure that
invariant stays the same right it's
still mapping all the names of customers
that i have in my thing
to their nodes okay so when something
leaves
i better need to make sure that both of
these things
are updated does that make sense okay so
how do i
maintain these operations we've got a
build
build just sets up empty of these things
right
you so you just say that i build an
empty
linked list doubly linked lists on the
customers and i build
a a set uh a hash table
mapping nothing to nothing right now
right okay
so that's build i'm gonna be precise
here and
actually write down the thing because i
told you not to
uh not to ignore
a operation or else we can't give you
points for it
the next one yeah i empty by building an
empty list
you mean like it just has like the head
and the taylor sets the none but
like it exists yeah right it's it's a
thing in memory that we store
it has a pointer to a head in the tail
those are none
right now but we will add things to it
right okay so the second one add name
right
what do we have to say we have to update
this data structure so it maintains it
to variance
right i have to usually i start with one
of them
uh i get to a point where oh i really
should have updated the other one first
right so sometimes it's hit or miss what
do i want to do here well
i have no idea where in this sequence
this is right
so i kind of have to go here first right
oh sorry adding a guy i could do either
way
right i know where is he gonna go
end of the list right so i can just
stick it there
right so add
x to end of
sequence all right so i already come to
a trick that i like
right sequence set
okay in this instance i only have one
sequence in one sentence it's calling
them sequence and set
probably fine right i'm not going to
confuse the greater i'm not going to
confuse myself
right but when i have more than one of
these things
or even for brevity on an exam where i'm
you know time constrained
give these things a name right say this
is a sequence
uh c and m i don't know i see customer
here i see map here so
you know maybe i don't know right but
just give them a letter
and we can follow you much more clearly
and you can refer to these things
more precisely right so end of
c okay uh
then what do we have to do i fix this
guy
this guy's good now i have to fix this
guy
so i add x to the set
and i map it back to that node that i
just came from right i could store it in
a temporary variable right
and x
to m pointing
to
in node v
to d okay cool
so i added my x to the end of c
into a node v right
and kind of whole i labeled it so i can
reference it later
right and kind of in code i would
probably remember what that node was
add x to m pointing to that node
right and now i've maintained my
invariant great maybe what's this
uh add key x
or add add x to m
having the key of x point to that note
does that make sense there's a little
subtle t there
okay three we have remove
i don't remember the name whatever okay
so here we have to do in order matters
right i don't know where it is in the
sequence
but i'm going to look it up in the set
i'm going to remove it from the set
and i'm going to look at whatever it
points to and remove it from the
sequence
okay i'm running out of time a little
bit here so i'm not going to write all
that down
you guys understand what that means here
we're using the fact that it's a doubly
linked list
so that we can re-link things together
you don't have to tell me
re-point the previous pointer of my next
thing
to the neck the right you don't have to
tell me how to relink those pointers
because we did that already in
problem set one or whatever right
just in general is there any situation
where you're using none
not a double linked list like just like
this would be better
like this because it seems like it
always solves problems yeah doubly
linked list is
almost always strictly better than a
single glass in theory problems so
yeah use it
okay uh and then seat last one
that's just take the front of the
sequence
remove it change the head around but i
i get that you can delete first right
you're reducing to the
interface that we had you're deleting
first on this sequence
okay but now we have a situation i
i deleted the first guy how do i know
who the first guy is
well i'm storing its name in there right
i'm storing the names of these customers
so i know who is at the front i look in
this set data structure
and i remove that entry does that make
sense because now i
no longer need to maintain where he goes
now in actuality
i could just not update this set data
structure
but if i do that then well my running
times are still linear time
right i'm not giving you a bound on
space i'm still
constant time sorry so you
don't actually have to do that removal
but
uh if that customer comes back and wants
to get on the wait list again
right you're right there there are
things to consider right
okay so that's that question
next question last 10 minutes or so
uh rainy research this was a problem
that
people had nightmares about
okay so basically we've got a mother
when
he's a weatherman a scientist who uh
studies global rainfall
uh and he's got a bunch of uh sensors
everywhere
and each one can post to the cloud or
something
a measurement that's of the form a
triple of integers
r l and t where r is a positive amount
of rainfall
an integer uh a latitude
uh an integer again and at a time okay
so we got three things to deal with here
yuck okay uh
but they're all integers and don't be
like oh well jason
latitudes are pretty small
so i can assume these integers are small
and these things take constant time
right i'm not specifying to you a
resolution at which i'm measuring these
integers so
and i haven't given you a bound between
what that resolution is compared to the
number of measurements that i have
so don't play those games okay uh the
peak rainfall at a given latitude
since a particular time is the maximum
rainfall
at any measurement at that latitude
measured at a time
greater than or equal to that time does
that make sense
or zero if there aren't measurements at
that latitude okay
just score after the time or before the
time or whatever
describe a database that we can build it
in constant time
right uh an empty one i added this one
because
we weren't good about that last spring
uh
record data we give you a triplet and
then
so record data for it to be correct i
just have to maintain that information
right
right for these kind of updates i don't
i
it's really hard for me to argue that
this thing is correct right
because i just you know i throw it at
the database the data
base doesn't have to give anything back
to me right
so the the important thing here about
correctness is that
peak rainfall gives it to me and it
gives it to me
in the time bound that i'm looking for
and p crane follows returning the peak
rainfall
at a particular latitude since t
okay so we have three things yep
given that you ever have to like a
single measurement
of it there's the potential that you
don't need to store all of the
information because
all we're doing is giving you back ours
essentially
right it's possible that you don't need
to store the latitudes or times at all
right you don't even need to store the
triplets now in reality i'm
querying on the latitudes and the times
i i should store them somewhere but i
might be able to compress them in
particular
right many things could be stored at the
same latitude
right that's kind of the whole point of
the query and so we want
i mean we may only need to store that
latitude once does that make sense
okay i'm going to wait for questions
until after because i want to get to
a solution to this problem all right so
uh what do we need to do we need to be
able to add things
and i want to return so return i'm going
to have to query something
right and then i'm going to return
something right so return peak rainfall
at latitude l since time t
what do i care about in a particular
query i only care about all the things
at l
right at a latitude l so
really i this isn't such an interesting
thing but i want to be able to have
maybe many data structures one
associated with each l
does that make sense right and how can i
find
one in each l right quickly
put in a dictionary what's my time bound
worst case log n right so what data
structure i use for that set data
structure
a set avl right so we're going to first
have a
set avo
say l
mapping
latitudes dudes
to well now we have more data structures
right i want to store a lot of the
things that have the same latitudes
in another data structure right the ones
probably
storing the times and the rainfalls of
all those measurements yeah
uh yeah a hash table okay so what kinds
of query am i going to want to
do on the things at the same latitude
you're going to get the times
i'm going to want to get the times but
more than that i'm doing kind of a
an ordered query right i need the things
less than a certain time
right
okay do i care about an avl for the rain
do am i looking up
on the rainfall
no right so i'm going to go ahead and
store these things in a
time sorted avl right
to mapping
latitude l
to i'm going to call this data structure
a time data structure right i'm going to
say it's
t of l okay that kind of looks like a
recurrence so it's a little irking me
right now but i don't have anything
better
all right so now each one of these time
data structures
right is a
set avl
mapping
time to
the you know the rainfall measurement
right
all right so that's gonna if my query
was return the peak rainfall
sorry return the rainfall
of the thing with latitude l and time t
we'd be done kind of right you you'd
know how to support that query
right i to insert things i insert things
into both data structures i just look it
up
right the one complication here is that
i'm not asking for
what is the rainfall at a particular
time
i don't know what the maximum rainfall
is up to this time
okay so max heap's good if i want to
know the global max
right but here i want to know the max
bounded by a certain range
okay so i we're gonna
you can ask me questions after this
we're running out of time a little bit
okay so anyone have an idea for how
yeah can you just augment the avl with
the max
okay you can just look at the right
child and just look at the backs of that
ah okay so what your colleague is saying
if we augment by the max
r in my subtree
maybe we can use that to figure out this
query
right because we're ordered on t right
we have this nice monotonic property
that
everything that's going to be in my
query
right everything to the right of a
certain time
right if if my time is
in is above t right at a particular node
then everything in the right subtree is
also
above that t right because of the
order of my sets data structure right
because i'm ordered on times
right so there's maybe the possibility
that if i look to my right subtree
i can not do work all over here
by just looking at the max in that
subtree right so that's an idea of
let's say augmented
by sub tree
max r okay i probably want to give this
a name as well
right so like v max
right where v is a node in my sub in my
thing right
and i want to show how to support this
right how i can compute that from its
children
so how do i actually support this query
right
i can think of it recursively right
i have a couple cases if i'm at a v here
i want to define a recursive function
that's called
uh you know peak
peak rainfall of a given node
lower bounded by a t okay
so if i'm here there's two cases right
either my t my time is
bigger or small easy in my range or out
of my range right
if it's out of my range what do i do
right it's lower than my time bound
i can just recursively call this
function on this node
right because i know that any thing
is going to be down here that i care
about right
and that's just one recursive call down
the tree right and so
if i only limit myself to one recursive
call down the tree
i'm always going down each time this is
going to take logarithmic time
right okay so that's the first case
that's the easy case
right this thing is not in range i
return recursively
the thing to my right what's the other
case i'm in my range
right well now i could return
recursively call both sides
right because that's what this this peak
is talking about what's my peak rainfall
but if i do that if i call it here
recursively and i call it here
recursively
that could take linear time right i
might touch every node in my tree
so why did i do this augmentation so i
don't have to do work on this node
and just return the maximum rainfall in
this subtree
right and then recurse on this side
so i did constant work on this side
i did one recursive call down here which
could go to the bottom
that's okay i can afford to go to the
bottom of the tree
that makes sense and if i don't have
either subtree
then i'm done right if i if at any time
i
don't have the node that i'm supposed to
recurse on
right i take the max of this subtree
myself and whatever the recursive return
value is here
right and comparing three values
returning their max
does that make sense okay so that's what
we call a one-sided range query
okay so uh
in the i think problem session four that
i didn't get to
it shows you a way to do this for a
two-sided range query
where i need to know like the maximum of
all things between two
things right but it's really no more
difficult than this
defining a recursive function that uses
an augmentation
so that you don't have to do recursive
call on both sides
that make sense okay that's going to be
it for now
and i can take questions after okay
thanks for coming